hi guys and girls good morning today I
want to I want to talk about something
which i think is really paramount
fundamental really important to improve
our lives which is reading as to
remember when it was eleven that my
grandmother took me aside when we were
at the sea at my house of the sea and
she told me Luka do you want to do some
Latin do you want to do some French do
you want to do some math and I you know
we can imagine that for an
eleven-year-old who wants to go to the
sea and play without her kids this was
kind of a strange Indecent Proposal but
um I just immediately said yes I started
working with my grandmother on on on
French and maths and on Latin and I
don't remember exactly what we worked on
but he still do remember that she gave
me this invaluable thirst for knowledge
or I wanted to understand more I wanted
to understand myself I wanted to
understand the world better and this
thing has definitely changed my life and
so it went I just started reading a book
after book so you can imagine this
little guy me reading a lot a ton of
books sitting in the garden instead of
even going to to the beach and this has
had a huge impact on my life the
impression I have nowadays is that we
read less less myself included because
we tend to spend a lot of time on
Facebook a lot of time in YouTube a
Twitter Instagram whatever we're just
ago sedated we're just overwhelmed by by
technology and I think that it's still
really valuable when we slow down when
we just take the time maybe 30 minutes a
night and we read a book for those who
have done that you you might have
noticed that when you actually read a
book in silence time almost slows down
because when we spend time on the
Internet we tend to be overwhelmed by
all these things is as I was saying um
but I don't want this this this video
just to be something vague about reading
I just wanted to talk more specifically
this was a premise reading can actually
change your life but what I want to talk
about is how to read for example to
improve your
language right so let me give you a
piece of advice this is just the first
part so it's not going to be everything
you can find more information on my blog
I'm putting together a series of cool
videos about this more specific but just
let me give you some general tips first
of all the very first important tip is
that if you don't read any more get back
into reading and as stephen krashen says
and i think i agree with that read
whatever whatever comes to your mind it
doesn't have to be necessarily if I have
you know super nice literature everybody
says okay you have to rejoice because
Joyce is like the literature at its
finest if you like Joyce or not you know
Ulysses as they say it's a it's a
masterpiece but if you don't like you're
not going to read it so the very first
thing that you should do is to think
okay I want I'm reading this I'm
learning this language I want to read
something that interests me it might
sound trivial but the reality is that a
lot of people tend to do things or tend
to read things or tend to study stuff
that they fundamentally don't like that
I think that language learning is
progressive but it's not necessarily
linear so the very first thing is to get
hold of things that you actually like
and it can be anything the other thing
which is I think is paramount is get
into the habit of reading at least
thirty minutes a night before going to
sleep for example you just don't do
anything else no music no internet just
turn off that computer which you're but
you're actually using now or you're
using an iPhone whatever and just focus
on plain reading and silence get into
the habit of that and just decide
beforehand this very same moment when
you're watching this video okay from now
on I'm going to read 30 minutes a night
this is going to change my life I didn't
believe that in the moment when my
grandmother told me this is going to
make the difference in your life this is
going to make you smarter this is going
to make you connect the dots this is
going to make you see things connect
things you're you're going to understand
more I said well this this is something
that Ranma says to everybody you know
they just didn't believe it but in order
to believe things and in things you have
to live them and I
lived and I can tell you that just 30
minutes can actually change your life
the way you see live they use the you
see life in general so my suggestion is
that if you don't do it just get back
into the habit of doing it and it can be
30 minutes at first and then
progressively you can put more and more
time into reading this is not just for
knowledge but reading comes your mind
because you can see that while you read
you can actually go deeper in your mind
and imagine things there are numerous
advantages about of reading in general
you can simply type for example Google
advantages of reading you will see a
huge list of things that are great for
you for your mind and another tip which
is an unconventional tip I would say is
that you might say well look I'm just
intermediate-level in French or Spanish
or Russian how can I actually find stuff
that can can I can read because the
problem of reading books is sometimes
it's difficult to understand them
because the the words the vocabulary the
level of vocabulary that is used in
books is can be higher than your actual
vocabulary the one you use every day
my suggestion is really simple when
remember read something that you're
interested in this is really important
but open take a book go to the library
for example or to the bookshop and grab
a book open above any page then read
this page and if this page contains more
words more than 20 words that you don't
know probably it is at a level that is
not yours and it's going to be difficult
to read a book like that because reading
there is extensive reading intensive
reading I'll talk about that but in
general when you read a book for the
pleasure of it when you want to relax
but you also want to learn a language so
you want to combine things you have to
find a balance if a book is too
difficult it sounds like it looks like
homework and it gets too complicated so
open a book and if you see that this
book contains for any page contains more
than 20 words that you don't know that
book is probably not for you and you can
actually go and look for
another book to make your life easier at
the beginning because the beginning is
going to be a little bit hard if you
don't find the right book another
suggestion is that I also give for
movies is that if you want you can
actually start with books that you have
already read in your native tongue or in
another language because you already
know the content and you already know
the story so this makes things much
easier I'm putting together a series of
videos as I said about reading with you
know practical tips on how to do that
this is just an introduction but the
real message here is that reading can
actually change your life it's not just
because you're going to learn a language
better it's because the perception you
have of reality is going to change and
it's going to be shaped also by what you
read I want to conclude I found here a
couple of thoughts about reading which I
really like and I'm going to read it for
you for some inspiration morning
inspiration it's morning and the first
one goes like that
the more that you read the more things
you will know the more that you learn
the more places you will go
dr. Seuss and another one is a reader
lives a thousand lives before he dies
said Jojen but the man who never reads
his only lived once thank you very much
for listening to me bye